can you hear me at the back oh that's
better if I'm in front of this mic but I
have miced up so you should be able to
hear me all over if I step over here you
should be able to hear
me okay scream if you can't hear me
because I'm a bit soft spoken at the
moment due to laryngitis or something I
don't know what it is anyway as
uh King Charles said when opening
parliament's day Lords ladies and
gentlemen
it it's very good to be back at
Hillsdale I was here what maybe 8 years
ago talking about KES and
Hayek and on the bill it said that I was
going to speak about haek
kanes which makes sense I suppose as
we're in Hillsdale I see even though
that my book is called Samuelson fredman
I'm build is talking about fredman
Samuelson just so that I know who to
Pander to you
know
uh I'm going to be light on Samuelson
because in a way I think fredman is more
interesting character particularly in
these
times
uh these two guys were friends for
almost the whole of their lives they met
when they were about 20 years old in
Chicago
University uh Milton Freedman was three
years
older than Paul Samuelson but Paul
Samuelson was a child prodigy
who was three years younger than Milton
and they turned up at the same class at
the same time which showed how well in
advance Paul Samuelson was in terms of
his
intellect Paul Samson came from Gary
Indiana not too far away from here his
father was a
pharmacist so he had nothing to do with
the steel industry except by one remove
his father in those days this is way
before anybody thought of universal
healthcare or indeed Healthcare at all
he used to be used the pharmacist as
indeed in my childhood the pharmacist
was used as someone who could give
advice while the doctor was too busy to
see you or if you couldn't afford the
doctor uh Milton Friedman was born and
brought up in Brooklyn then in the
southern part of New Jersey he lost his
father very young and didn't have all
the advantages that Paul Samson had not
that Paul Samson had many advantages but
he won every scholarship he ever went
into so he was constantly funded if not
overfunded Milton's wife Rose Freedman
always held a grudge against Paul
samelson who she thought was sort of
super funded super entitled because he'd
done so well in life and poor Milton was
the
underdog well not that you could tell
that from Milton who was an immensely
confident person they met in the same
class as I say because in those days
universities used to tell you where to
sit the opening class at Chicago had
allocated seats for everybody in the
lecture hall by
alphabet which put Milton fredman next
door to a woman
called
uh
Rose you got
it and that was the beginning of Love
Fair which then lasted for 70
years although Paul Samuelson and Milton
didn't have a love affair they were very
close to each other even though they
sharply disagreed really from the get-go
about what
happened their understanding of History
how the Great Depression took place the
causes of the Great Depression ways out
of the depression the role of government
in steering an economy in order to make
the world more prosperous or not whether
indeed it was possible at all to use the
government as a means of changing the
economy or whether morally you should
allow a government to alter and direct
an
economy Chicago then was the beginning
Chicago was one of the rare
places where the economics Department
was entirely
conservative there were maybe six
prominent people that who stood the test
of time
and there are very few universities in
United States considering how many there
are it's pretty bizarre George Mason is
maybe another one that teaches not
conventional kesan
economics but of course they were
starting off when canes was barely
known they were there right at the
beginning of the depression in the early
30s
3132 this book that I've written
Samuelson Friedman
is really a sequel to Kane's haek
because it follows exactly the
same logic that kanes and Hayek
followed Hayek was an a Austrian
Economist so-called he was literally an
Austrian came from Vienna and he was a
microeconomist who never really gave
credit to John mayard kan's revolution
in 1936 with the general theory when
macro economics became the rage and it's
remained the rage ever since in a way
economics is
macroeconomics
microeconomics is well still alive and
going well in some places but on the
whole if you want a job in a bank you
read
macroeconomics the reason that uh they
disagreed was
interesting Paul Samson always put it
down to the way that they understood
what the Great Depression was
about Paul Samson had great empathy with
his father's clients the people would go
to the pharmacist to get
their relatively cheap cures for
whatever they were suffering
from Milton had a much tougher life
really pulled himself up by the
bootstraps his mother was sold Dry Goods
we're talking about
oats
SEO dried spaghetti things like that
anything that didn't need a refrigerator
she sold as a grocer but it didn't bring
very much money but it was made very
clear to Milton very early on that he
would be allowed to be educated as far
as he could go as long as he was
self-funding that put the two men young
men
at a great distance really from each
other whereas Paul
Samuelson who was well funded throughout
didn't need to work in fact he wouldn't
apply for jobs because if he got a job
he would deprive someone else who needed
the money more than he did Milton
Friedman did everything in order to get
enough money in order to pay for the
school fees for the books and the other
things that he
needed lateer in life Paul Samuelson
said that he thought that that was the
profound difference which displayed the
difference between the two of them and
their approach to economics and what it
should
attain Paul S samelson like John Maynard
KES was appalled by the misery caused by
the Great Depression he thought it was
unforgivable that millions should be
thrown out of work through no fault of
their
own and so when John mayad KES came to
the general theory Paul Samuelson was
Absol absolutely in the right place
because KES too although KES was very
well provided for both parents were
academics and they at Cambridge
University he went to Eaton one of the
great Elite colleges in uh Britain then
went on to Cambridge
himself was a student at King's College
Cambridge which is the most
distinguished College of all those of in
Cambridge
th this gave him a rather paternalistic
view of what a government May
achieve really using the benefits of the
state in order to try to get someone a
leg up if
possible but he was also a mighty
intellect CES and so he founded a way of
explaining how you could
actually effectively live live in the
future today you could borrow from the
future in order to put people back to
work today and that by spending money
today through what he called the
multiplier effect that was for every
dollar you spend it was passed on to
someone else who spent it who then
passed to someone else who then spent it
and so on each dollar that a state
invested in an economy was worth far
more than that so he found it what he
thought was a cheap way of getting
people back to
work Milton was different he that really
you had to earn every penny best not to
take credit best not for the government
to get involved in things at all he
believed in the free market as a the
solution to
everything Paul samelson would say that
there wasn't enough
time for the free market to work
although the market would work out
eventually he would say there's no point
an economist telling you that weeks
after a storm had subsided that the
ocean would be flat you needed the the
ocean to be flat today or next week in
order to be of benefit to
anybody let's just
see
Paul samelson let's just fill him in
then we can get him out of the
way excuse me because there's no real
benefit much in going through Paul
samuelson's life as it was a dotal
throughout he won a scholarship in
Chicago the only thing that the
scholarship said was you can take up a
post somewhere else but it may not be in
the University you were in so he was
obliged to leave Cho Chicago which he
thought was a great benefit because that
gave him a wider take on things he took
his Doctorate at
Harvard and the dissertation his
doctrinal
dissertation which schuma you may
know judged said was beyond his means of
judging because it was so beyond his
understanding but it was
correct so Samson became a doctor at
Harvard
and he might have expected to be taken
then on to the faculty of Harvard but
instead he was offered a lowly lectur
ship well this he didn't think much of
at all his doctoral thesis it turned out
some years later was the thing that was
going to win him the Nobel Prize and yet
the economics department at Harvard
didn't take its Brilliance into account
so instead he walked across the Charles
River and volunteered to teach at MIT
which in those days was a rather modest
engineering
College he found out sometime later that
it was the head of Economics at Harvard
a wasp who was anti-semitic and would
not credit Jews however well they did
with with the position they deserved it
was not a meritocracy and he never
forgave Harvard for that instead he
happily transformed MIT from being a
lowly engineering College into the
powerhouse that it is today MIT with a
worldwide reputation in its way every
bit as important as
Harvard now Milton much more interesting
case in a way he went to succession of
universities which weren't part of the
ivy league he went to Rutgers University
although in those days it was a private
university he uh he did very well there
he then went on to
Colombia this is all very within PR in
as you can imagine of New York City he
didn't travel very
far and he got a succession of jobs now
in the 30s he and Rose they married
relatively young got a
job
together applying the
economic statistical measurements of an
economy that kanes had invented in the
term of economic
econometrics and they did it for the New
Deal they were hired by the government
in order to measure whole succession of
important um measures by which you could
tell whether there any progress was
being made out of the New Deal spending
the jobs being created by government
spending and so
on he gives credit to that although he
said it was ironic that he should after
all do well out of the new deal as it
wasn't really intended for him but in
many respects of course the New Deal was
intended for anybody any anybody who
didn't have a job could be able to get a
job but for Milton who didn't believe in
government
intervention it was a an ironic position
to be
in another thing that he did was to look
carefully at the reasons for the Great
Depression it was John mayai K's point
of view who was the commonly held
assumption for many many years for
decades So what had happened in the
Depression was that there were
too much money chasing too few stocks
which created a bubble which then burst
bringing the whole world down with
it Milton and a woman called Anna
Schwarz who died about five years
ago set about looking at the details of
the money supply during the key periods
of the 20s and 30s and came to the
conclusion surprising conclusion that it
wasn't too much money in the system it
was too little money in the system if
the government had lent money to the
banks and kept them afloat then the
Great Depression need never have
happened this was a revolutionary
thought and was in many respects a
Keynesian view of looking at
things if the state is going to hose
money at banks in order to keep
everybody afloat that's exactly what
John May KES had been suggesting all
along